[Music]
this is live stream shopping
one of the hottest trends in china every
night
tens of millions of people watch live
shows hosted by influencers like thea
and by the products they recommend on
e-commerce and social apps like taobao
and do-ing
the sister app of tick-tock
functions
it's not about you know only shopping
it's about the experience it's about
having fun
you got to see 3d you got to see in some
kind of action
it's almost like a theater act the
internet craze has taken over china
by the end of 2020 the country had
almost
400 million live stream shopping users
china's livestream e-commerce market has
also grown dramatically
with an estimated value of 161 billion
dollars in 2020
it's becoming popular outside china as
well
so is live streaming the future of
shopping
[Music]
live streaming is not a new thing in
china it started in 2015 with the
rollout of 4g
and it was first used for entertainment
and socializing
many live streamers performed for their
followers or chatted to them
making money by receiving virtual
currency and gifts
in the west live streaming is mainly the
domain of avid gamers
in china it's broken into e-commerce
china actually has a very big e-commerce
empire so it uses these
super apps what we call that you have
payment you have search of information
you have recommendation system
and you have huge amount of goods
available on the platform
and as well as a lot of consumers so
with this advantage they
merge these features of live streaming
to make the influencers actually so good
here is a perfect choice nice neutrals
beautiful print nothing overwhelming and
the warmth and comfort of flannel
this is item traditional tv shopping
involves a one-way direction
whereby a host introduces a product
demonstrate certain things and say call
this number or something
but live stream shopping is live that in
itself is a very very big difference
it causes different psychology and live
stream shopping is a very entertaining
way of actually engaging someone else
when you shop actually this live
streaming video will continue
it will minimize into a corner and you
can like buy the items
and pay all on the same app after that
the live streaming screen
will just enlarge by itself and the
promoter will come back to screen
so it's like very convenient
how about one of china's biggest
e-commerce platforms owned by tech giant
alibaba
added a live streaming function in early
2016.
in the following years other e-commerce
and social platforms like jd and do-ing
also integrated this feature
over 70 billion dollars worth of goods
was sold by a live stream
on taobao in the year through march 2021
latest surveys show that over 60 of live
stream users in china
were watching shopping shows and over 65
of them shopped at least once via live
stream
in 2020 live stream shopping got a huge
boost during the pandemic
when millions of people were in lockdown
and many retailers were pushed
online people you know during the
lockdown
felt like there's a need for more social
interactions
this live platform creates an
interesting
kind of uh environment that gives people
this sense that i'm actually interacting
with you
and then live stream shopping brings in
a lot more variety of things that people
could buy and satisfy
you know the sense the sense of losing
control especially during pandemic
at the heart of this craze are the top
influencers
who have tens of millions of followers
and some products worth millions of
dollars
every night they often use their stock
power
to get bargains from retailers which in
turn boosts their own sales and
influence
so if you think about china's live
streaming you have to know the
king and queen of the influences the
queen of live streaming
via she is actually having the biggest
viewership
and or the biggest sales volume for a
long time
on taobao platform she can sell
everything from
like gucci sunglasses lipsticks
homes and cars one time she offered her
followers to
go on a tesla ride with her and she even
for once saw the rocky launch in her
live streaming room for 40 million yen
the king b lijachi more widely known as
lipstick's brother
he used to be a cosmetic cells
before he turned into live streaming
e-commerce
and he knows a lot about the cosmetics
so he's the one that will actually put
the lipsticks on himself when
he's on the show
top live streamers like via and lijachi
have become celebrities in china and can
earn millions of dollars a year
although not everyone can be as popular
mid-ranking live streamers like tiffany
still earn a good income through sales
commissions
is
engineering
[Music]
[Music]
me
a lot of successful live streamers are
generally very good at communication
they're very good at articulating very
simply what the product does what a
product doesn't do in order for them to
sell they need to be trustworthy
and appear trustworthy and they need to
you know show in some ways that they're
authentic right so for vr and
chassis they're able to articulate that
quite a bit through their body language
through what they say for example uh the
chiacchi will also sometimes say things
and bad things about certain products
because to him there's this honest
opinion and sometimes people want to
hear that
and so they seem very credible they seem
very trustworthy and don't forget
they're also very entertaining and very
interesting
if you're familiar with echassi he won a
guinness record for like the most
lipstick applications to models in
30 seconds
so if you're able to create a lot of
buzz with interesting things that you do
people who may not want to buy lipsticks
but also streaming just to watch what he
does
and then from there you might get hooked
situationally by using two minute show
to the comedy and stuff
live streamers also use sales techniques
such as limited time or supply
this sense of scarcity can often
encourage viewers to buy
the platform in itself creates and
enhances some of these things but you
see live
something because social proof has taken
over meaning that hey
other people are interested other people
are joining in other people want the
same product
and they add it in a chat and they ask
questions and say oh i want this too
what happens then it makes the whole
product even more scarce
but it's not just influencers local
farmers
luxury brands even mutual funds have
also started their own live stream shows
working with very top tier live
streamers can be risky
it's not necessary that the benefits
will end up with a brand
so we see company executives opening
their own shows
and we see like png have their own sales
room which runs
shows every day as well we also have
like local governors in
like small towns to sell their
agricultural products
so the live streaming is definitely
transformed the way
product owners can think about how to
reach their consumers
and enables a lot of players to actually
sell
live stream shopping is going global
merchants in southeast asia have
embraced this trend
and in the west amazon has upgraded its
live streaming function
adding interactive features like chat
rooms
companies including google and facebook
are also developing and investing in
technologies
to integrate video and e-commerce
data
if you look at the numbers alone their
numbers are only just these numbers of
years now
you know that they can sell and you know
that you know they can generate revenue
are they able to sustain it over a long
period of time
it depends on how innovative they are at
changing some of the things they do
but you can't expect consumers one day
turn
into virtual shopping for good there
will be the nature of us that crave
to go into the store to touch the goods
and actually wear it and
see how it looks like and walk around in
that with our friends
and those things wouldn't be replaceable
with live streaming
you